podría dar una renovación y ampliar la
protección de los derechos de las
mujeres o en este sentido como lo decía
talia el país no va a cambiar tanto no
va a cambiar tanto al corto plazo porque
ya está como inserto en el ADN de cierto
nivel de población un poco adulta y las
feministas lo que se ha visto en en las
marchas y demás es cómo viene la
represión tan fuerte él no puede liberar
una carta de derechos tan próxima porque
sabe que hay una gran oposición en el
país además lo que estamos viendo en las
elecciones de la alianza no tendría la
mayoría y esto jugaría en contra de esa
posibilidad de hacer reformas Lo que sí
es importante destacar Es que viniendo
el partido quemalista el partido
original de Turquía de la República fue
el partido que le dio el voto a la mujer
si es él está en deuda y muy pendiente
de generar una modernización en el
tratamiento que se le da porque sabemos
ese discurso radical de edwan donde
también manifiesta que la mujer no
debería ir tanto a la universidad y a
otros sistemas educativos porque su
labor es estar en la casa es claramente
si debería darse pero sabe el candidato
que de ganar en una segunda vuelta
porque estamos en riesgo en eso de que
no haya potencialmente este contexto
básicamente sabe que tiene una gran
riesgo de hacerlo muy pronto y en qué
aspectos que sí podría traer una
modernización este líder opositor en la
economía que sería muy importante el
tema de ver más mujeres emprendedoras
que eso generaría una dinámica muy
fuerte de ese lado mujeres que
representen más a la industria y el tema
diplomático que se ha perdido también y
obviamente volver a estas convenciones
dentro de la Organización de Naciones
Unidas y otros organismos
internacionales que son muy relevantes
para entender cómo es la realidad
interna de la mujer en